it takes a lot of hard work and good
luck to get a movie made but all of that
can be ruined in an instant with just
one bad decision sometimes it doesn't
matter how good the story is or how
famous the stars are because a single
moment of stupidity can wash it all away
here's a look at some promising movies
that were cancelled because of a really
dumb decision at the mountains of
madness the masterwork of horror and
science fiction author HP Lovecraft at
the mountains of madness has long been a
passion project for horror
art or Guillermo del Toro and del Toro
seems like the perfect fit for the tale
of a group of scientists who discover
ancient terrifyingly powerful entities
in Antarctica unfortunately despite
James Cameron producing and interest
from Tom Cruise del Toro couldn't get
funding from Universal because he told
them it would be r-rated meaning the
teens who usually flock to horror movies
wouldn't be able to see it the project
was canceled and del Toro later said he
should have lied to executives and told
them that the mountains of madness would
be pg-13 hey lo there were a lot of dumb
decisions that led to the demise of the
proposed halo movie mostly because
Microsoft apparently had no idea how
Hollywood works they demanded a huge cut
of profits and forced Studios to jump
through hoops to even have a chance to
read the script plus they wouldn't let
Sony bid on the film at all because
Sony's PlayStation is one of Microsoft
Xbox a--'s chief video game console
competitors despite all that nonsense
Fox and Universal were both still
interested and teamed up but then they
made the final dumb decision in this
whole dumb process when Universal hired
up-and-comer Neill Blomkamp to direct
Blomkamp was a fan of the game with a
distinct artistic vision the problem is
only Universal wanted him both Fox and
Microsoft reportedly hated what he was
doing running instead to make what the
director called a generic boring film
something like GI Joe or some crap like
that ultimately the only thing that came
of it was some test footage that teases
the great halo movie that could have
been and blomkamp he went on to make
district 9 instead great job Microsoft
Uncle Tom's fairy tales
in 1968 Richard Pryor wrote and starred
in an extremely dark socially conscious
movie with the intentionally
controversial title Uncle Tom's
fairytales the movie for homosexuals
Pryor supposedly became so obsessed with
making the film his wife reportedly
destroyed the negative of the then still
unfinished movie in a fit of rage nearly
four decades later another trend of the
film emerged thanks to director Penelope
Spheeris but so far it hasn't been
released either for legal reasons
ho-yang based on Deedle eels intense
graphic novel about the struggles of
living under the totalitarian regime in
North Korea Hong yang was supposed to
start shooting in early 2015 with Steve
Carell in the lead role and Gore
Verbinski Asst director then Sony
decided to release the interview in 2014
that reportedly led to the infamous hack
of the Sony servers in retaliation
not to mention bomb threats against
theaters that screen the interview New
Regency decided Tong yang wasn't worth
the hassle and canceled the film
entirely the Beatles version of Lord of
the Rings jr. our tokens the Lord of the
Rings books ranked among the most
beloved novels of all time first
published as three separate volumes in
1954 it took until 2001 for Peter
Jackson's epic live-action adaptation to
hit movie theaters but there was an
earlier version proposed in the 1960s
and it would have starred the Beatles
yeah those Beatles besides doing a brand
new double album soundtrack The Beatles
were set to star in the live-action
adaptation with Paul McCartney as Frodo
Ringo Starr is Sam wise George Harrison
is Gandalf and John Lennon and his
Gollum unfortunately Tolkien wasn't a
Beatles fan and he decided to nix the
idea otherwise both music and cinematic
history would have been completely
different and much much weirder thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]